hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer question from one of our
readers Rita who wrote insane I'm into
network marketing and recruiting
qualified people into my team is a
problem how do I get the right people
onto my team so thanks for the question
Rita the way I look at network marketing
is similar to a franchise in business
and if you want to franchise your
business what you have to be able to do
number one is show that it can work
yourself so a lot of people get into
network marketing they don't have any
success and actually selling what all
they do is try to go out and recruit
people to join their team in the grand
scheme of things you're gonna make money
by having a profitable team who's out
there selling for you but you have to
know how to do it yourself you have to
build a model where you're out selling
making money so when you're talking to
people and trying to convince them to
come on board you can show them hey I've
done this this works and this can work
for you so number one is making sure
that you're able to sell the product
yourself you believe in it you've had
success and you can duplicate that
success by bringing other people on
board if you go on your pitching people
and you haven't had much access yourself
it's gonna be really hard to convince
him to want to sign up with you ok so
that's number one the second thing is
I'd really make sure I'm qualifying
people so you don't want to just accept
anybody into your program if you want to
have a successful network marketing
business or any business really you
really have to make sure that you're
spending the time training and
communicating with your people so
there's a lot of time investment right
you don't want to just sign somebody up
and say here you go and hopefully you
know they do well it's not really like
that if you look at the most successful
business owners and in network marketing
or any company you'll find that they've
invested into their team so it takes a
lot of time to put that work into your
team you want to make sure that you're
getting a commitment up front and not
wasting your time on somebody who's not
going to commit back to you so think
about the personality characteristics
you want to somebody working in your
business think about some qualifying
questions you can ask with some tasks
you can have them do to make sure that
they're really committed to doing this
before you go down the road or spending
a lot of time and effort with them and
they leave your business they don't have
success they drop it to do something
else so make sure you're really
qualifying upfront before we accept
somebody up onto your team you have a
lot more success with three or five
really highly motivated energetic people
who really want to make this work than
fifty people who have just signed up and
don't do anything with it right so
really focus on the quality they're over
the quantity and in the last bit advice
I have for you is make sure you stick
with them so assuming you found the
right person and you've built up a
system where you've done it yourself and
you can help people you have to train
them and mentor them starting in any
business is really hard right there's a
lot of excitement at the beginning and
that there at the start you're you're
feeding off of those fumes of excitement
and energy but then reality hits you and
you notice this is a lot harder than I
thought it was gonna be and at that
point a lot of these guys will drop off
and you don't want that to happen so you
have to show them that there is a way if
they stick with it they're gonna make
money they're gonna be successful and
you guide and mentor them along that
path so it's not just signing up new
people it's also continuing with your
existing people the ones you've put a
lot of time and effort into until
they're past their survival point once
somebody gets the system and they're
making enough money to support
themselves feed their families live
their lives then they can expand on that
success and you don't have to put as
much ongoing effort into it if they have
questions they want to mentor you have
to be there for them that's part of
being the boss being at the top but you
don't want to bend them them too early
and a lot of archers make this mistake
is they bring people on they give them a
little bit of training and say okay here
you go you've got to work with them
through those hard times especially at
the beginning and in network marketing
especially because it is tough to get
those first sales and if they don't see
some really success they're gonna get
discouraged and they're gonna quit on
you and so you've spent all this time
building up a system and recruiting and
training and you don't want people to
abandon ship because they don't have
immediate success so set them up for
success as much as you can and stick
with them through those hard times
especially at the beginning so that they
stay motivated to want to stay on your
team and continue building their own
little business so hopefully that helps
for those of you watching if you like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes me want to do more of
these videos for you and I'd love to
hear you have to think about this video
if you want to leave a comment under the
under below and we have a question about
your own business feel free to ask it I
love seeing those and I try to respond
to everybody sometimes taking a little
bit but I'll try to respond as soon as I
can so thank you and you'll see you on
the next episode